[Music]
another big winner last night and visit
us for favorite new TV drama now
millions of people are totally obsessed
with this series but eg on lines Li and
Aguilera uncover some things that even
the die-hard fans don't know about
I know Seger I know that it takes you
three and a half hours in the makeup
chair and it takes about an hour and a
half to take it off yeah on the show
Mandy goes from age 27 to 66 and she
plays lots of years in between the only
complaints I might register is that it
is so harsh on my skin and I'm super
sensitive skin so like a couple of days
of wearing the prosthetics it's my face
is just angry one of the things that I
think audiences don't know is in the
first draft of the pilot they had a line
that Jack was no longer alive and then
they took that out was there ever a
moment that you thought oh maybe they
changed their minds and Jack had live no
no I knew always that Jack was no longer
and I was okay with it and next on our
list of things you didn't know about
this is us Milo / jack is gonna shave
the mustache there will come a time
where Jack loses it and we're gonna see
a different side of Jack you ever
self-conscious like pull this off maybe
you know but then you just do it you're
like well that's what it is we all know
Tobey survived his heart attack and
proposes to Kate played by Crissy Mets
but Chris Sullivan told us details about
the fat suit he wears on set every day
yeah the costume pads me out about a
hundred and fifty pounds probably it's a
it's a pair of pants that I pull up wear
suspenders and then it's a jacket that
zips up the back no it only takes it
only takes about ten minutes to get on
and even it comes off even faster the
show's original title was actually 36
based on the ages of the big three it
was also at once called happy birthday
and I remember we did our first photo
shoot and my lowest so he's always been
like the captain of the ship and he's
like oh guys we're not putting on the
birthday hat so I'm like
of course it's no secret the leading men
on the show looked pretty hot shirtless
but that's created a little rivalry
behind the scenes Justin and I like
anytime we do a scene together
inevitably people wind up on the floor
doing push-ups it doesn't have to be a
part of the scene we just wind up on the
floor doing push-ups we do like scenes
where we run a lot and you know you do
somebody takes in a you know 10-second
scene you end up running like two miles
right to get that done for the record
Justin stronger than me but a little bit
do you want me to tell them that you
said that or keep it to myself keep it
to yourself I don't want to getting a
big head got to keep them humble
[Music]
you